all right
connor connor where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
for symphony new jersey tell me about
how you grew up you had both your
parents um i did
i was actually adopted in fort worth
texas so
i didn't know my birth mom or my birth
father but um
i was adopted by a great family and uh
from what i've heard at least you know i
kind of looked out my mother
was in a home for i guess beating women
that's what i was told and my father was
in prison when i was born
so you know both my parents that i have
today are
you know they've worked their whole
lives never drank anything
so i i guess i looked up with that so
the family that adopted you was good
yes solid did you ever meet your
biology experience no i mean when i was
18 i got forms
that would allow me to release
information right
and i just feel like at that time
because i was so mixed up in other
things in my life i just never really
given much thought
and now being 26 years old i i figure
you know i've gone this long
without knowing or needing to know
really
and the people that put clothes on my
back and
you know did all these things for me all
these years you know those should be my
parents and
i kind of wouldn't want them to think
that
i would need to fill some type of void
in another way you know to seek them
because if they want to meet me they
know they know they would know where i
am
yeah and the way you were raised any any
any issues there any uh abuse or
anything like that
sounds pretty good not with me but with
my sister yes you know
i don't i don't completely understand
why you know my father would abuse my
sister a lot
and never really me but
you know i didn't really know what it
was when i was younger you know i
thought that was normal i thought
you know if you misbehave you get beaten
you know i get slapped and i'd fight my
dad here and there but
my sister would always always
get beaten by my father you know and
my father was a big man you know six
foot seven
tall ex-military like you know
but uh you know now that i'm older i
kind of understand
with having anger issues maybe i can
understand why but
i don't think i ever will you know
but i've been you know beaten like i
used to get made fun of in school like
i've been bullied my whole life but
never really at home you finished high
school yes
i finished high school in prison
actually i
uh got locked up when i was 15 to 18.
i got charged with the accessory to
vehicular manslaughter
and distribution of uh cds which is
controlled daydream substance
and we were in a car me and three of my
friends and
i sold the driver coke and marijuana and
uh he decided to go 90 miles an hour
and uh 15 mile an hour zone and we
t-boned
this guy and we uh apparently broke
every bone in his body
and his body was cut in half on the
scene
and uh yeah and i was already on
probation at the time already for
setting up stuff on fire because i used
to play with fire when i was a kid
which you know i look at it now as an
adult it's like you know what
like why you know so drugs come into
your life at what age
uh they came into my life at 10 years
old
when my babysitter was doing cocaine and
i
i mean i was always a curious child but
i saw her doing it and she left him out
on the counter by accident
and i saw her sniffing it and so i
sniffed it and i
threw up immediately and um
you know i don't i don't know why but
even though i was
very very sick i couldn't wait to do it
again
you know and then from there on
it was pills and cocaine
i only had i only did pills for one week
i did a roxy on a monday and by fr
that friday i was already doing heroin
so i didn't have a long run with pills
and
where i am you know a grandma heroin is
25
so it's very cheap and very affordable
but
it's very very dangerous
and today you're using what today i'm
using fentanyl
and crack and methamphetamine
all three you're living unscathed bro
yes you're in a tent or yes i'm in a
tent which is
falling apart which you know
i should be spending money on trying to
fix where i live to not let
rodents and what what else could
come in there you know but instead i you
know my addiction has been
going on for years straight you know
it's it's very hard
you know how many years you've been down
here
i'm going on five years now continuous
how do you support yourself um i sell
drugs
and if needed b
i will do things for money
that may affect my moral compass as a
man
which you know i don't
i don't really aim to do but i can't
i'm at the point where i can't go a
certain amount of time without being
well
yeah which means by any means necessary
you're more honest than most
but uh do you have any contact with your
family still or
yeah i do i mean you know
i i called my mother text her every
other day just to check in
touch base but that's more to uh
to please her you know she doesn't know
that i live on skid row she doesn't know
any of this
it's a she may think it in the back of
her mind and she doesn't admit it to me
but
you know she's she's been dealing with
me worrying about me for
26 years you know i kind of just
have made a healthy distance and a
boundary
because i just don't want my mother to
worry about me you know
since i've been out here the past four
years
part of my family's you know passed away
and
you know i'm the only addict in my
family besides my sister so
it's kind of you know i feel like the
black sheep
is your sister adopted as well yes and
we also share a birthday on the same day
do you feel like maybe the fact that you
and your sister are adopted
and your the rest of your family is
clean maybe
it's it's inherited i think so
i think that's definitely part of it you
know
you have other siblings or just just you
and yours just my sister
and um you know she's an addict too
besides me you know and it's crazy
because we're the only two that are
adopted
shared birthday on the same day we both
have a lot in common
and we're the only two that ended up
being drug addicts out of
a very big irish italian family you know
i have like 30 cousins you know
and you know growing up seeing my
cousins like go to school go to college
and
play sports like i played sports when i
was younger too but
i just couldn't hold it together you
know i don't know how people
can you know sniff cocaine just on the
weekends or drink a little
bit here and there and because i'm at
the point where like if i put something
in me and i like it it's
there's no off switch and unless i like
pass out
and i hate that i've gotten myself to
that point because i brought myself
there do you feel a lot of
shame and guilt over where you're at
very much
i have a i have two culinary degrees
like
i worked under great chefs like i've had
opportunities to
work in great kitchens out here
and you know and i have worked in good
kitchens out here but
i haven't been able to hold a job for
more than a few months because i can't
keep my addiction under control
you know it's a it's a it's always been
a problem
you know and there's no dabbling
like i can't like get clean and say i'm
just going to do this here and there
it's either all or nothing
same thing with sobriety too because i
have had time of sobriety
you know and it's but that's because i
did
everything that was suggested i took
suggestions kept an open mind
but the consistency wasn't there you
know
what do you think most people that don't
do drugs don't understand about
addiction
i think that they don't understand that
with
with having an addictive personality
or with not being
as strong as others maybe in the mind
that you have no shot you know my drugs
are designed
for pleasure like drugs weren't made
for us not to like them you know like i
didn't i've never met a drug i didn't
like
so for people that don't have the same
mindset or
understanding of addiction like me i
think that they
will never uh they're never
i mean i don't know like you gotta kind
of respect it too
i just feel like with i don't know it's
a weird not a weird question but i'm
trying to figure out like how i would
answer that
um i would say how
the best way for them to understand it
is to sit down with an addict
for 15 minutes and listen to
what they uh to someone that's being
honest with them
tell them all the things that they've
done for the drugs everything
like everything you know what i just
told you
you know that i've been out here for
four years and
there's plenty of people that i see
every day and they don't even know that
stuff you know
you know so
i is one of my interviewees said once
you're only as sick as your secrets
what's been the lowest point of your
life the lowest point in my life
i would say is when i
got out of prison when i was 18 and
of course i continued to get high you
know
i moved to fort lauderdale florida and
you know i know my sexual orientation
i'm straight but at the time
you know i my friend that i grew up with
in high school
his uh husband was madonna's
ex-party planner his name was gary
sanchez and i used to live with them in
fort lauderdale
and with them being gay and me being
straight
18 just got out of prison looking decent
i would say
you know they uh they offered me a job
in the porn industry
which i took and
unfortunately at that time was when i
first tried crack for the first time so
crack is a drug that requires a lot of
money so at 18 years old and me being in
florida for a month i was already doing
gay porn
and uh that's when i started basically
you know understanding the whole
male escort type of deal so i was
doing that for about a year out there
homeless in fort lauderdale
if anything shows the power of the drug
addiction that's it
yeah yeah yeah because it wasn't just a
bad decision
it was it was how desperate you were for
the drug right yeah
yeah very much so
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
that
changing your perspective on things can
really uh alter
how you look at everything else you know
like i wake up every day in a tent
with rats with roommates that i don't
particularly like
people want to hurt you out here i'm
white too mind you i'm the minority out
here so people don't like me already
because of my skin color
so the way i look at my
the way i change my perspective is
i'm doing all this now so maybe in the
future i don't have to
you know like i know i'm not done
getting high right now but eventually i
think i will be
you know i i also have a 10 month old
daughter
in baltimore that i haven't even met yet
because i've been out here getting high
so i just
my perspective that keeps me going and
keeps me like
motivated to try to not get myself in
trouble
and kind of stay under the radars that
one day i will be
clean enough and sober enough to hold my
daughter and be in the same room
with her and not have anyone else have
to worry about
how i'm going to take care of her but i
know that right now that that's not
going to happen
i really wish i could it's a great goal
but
do you think this time on the streets
has changed you
in what ways um
i'd say collectively being homeless
whether it's here i've been almost in
kensington
pennsylvania new jersey florida out here
and all it's taught me is
how to not i guess how to be a loner
because you know like i said people want
to hurt you is
we're homeless right so there's
obviously something wrong
you know whether you're homeless for
mental health addiction or
you're just a plain old [ __ ] like
these aren't really people
that are you don't really want to
meet your friends for life out here you
know what i'm saying and it took me a
little bit to understand that because i
was very
maybe nice or just uh
overly uh giving and i learned very
quickly that
i had a welcome mat on my forehead for
too long you know and
again survival was not the easiest thing
out here
it's tough being surrounded by hustlers
yes
everybody around you
how much responsibility do you take for
your situation
100
i mean i made the conscious decision you
know to
google where can i find drugs in
california
where's
like i came out here to get sober
originally you know but i got brought
into a uh
body brokering um
case situation so i i kind of just like
impulsively just left the whole sobriety
thing and
got high because i thought i was going
to prison you know
and now i'm on the other side of the
spectrum
and now people want to get me in
treatment
how do homeless communities compare
kensington and
the other places you've been to l.a
well this is the first place i've ever
seen tents ever i've never even gone
camping a day in my life
until i came out here i swore i swear
never
i couldn't make a ten up it took me two
hours
um at least with kensington and
uh like florida i'm used to
like abandoned houses right that's
that's what there is out there
for shelter i guess out here you can set
up a tent on the sidewalk and as long as
it's not on the street you're fine
i've never even heard of that before you
know
but there's there's balance between
the places like on the east coast you
see a lot more dead bodies
out here there's a lot more uh
i'd say there's a lot more shootings
that are quickly taken care of out there
you know there could be a shooting and
the body could lay on the street for 12
hours
you know because there's so much other
things going on
in the rampant sex is this out here is
that i'm sorry
all the sex that's out of control that
happens down here
yes there's a lot of that and that's
because of the math that's because of
matthew
that goes out elsewhere as well yeah
it almost seems sometimes that that's
what keeps everybody yeah
pulls them in that's the quicksand oh
and it's crazy because
you know how's the crack too crack2
and like i don't know how
like i've never done meth until i came
out here crack used to just be my thing
and that would get me going but meth
it's it's like viagra times 100.
you know yeah crazy
i mean i've heard i've only had one or
two interviewees tell me about it
tell me tell me what what your sex life
is like when you do you smoke
crystal met it's very uh
it's very active i mean you know
sometimes like
i know i explain what i do sometimes but
if i have funds and i have jokes you
know what i mean i have a little bit of
money
i'll smoke a little bit of crystal and
i'll walk up around here and try to get
myself a girl for
i don't know a half hour or something
you know
but like my my sex life doesn't get
out of control but that's more because
people out here will kidnap you you know
like you get in the car with the wrong
person are you getting the wrong
tent it could be over for you
very easily whether you're a guy a girl
or hi or
both you know so when i have sex usually
it's at my place
or unless i'm doing something for money
that's
that's a whole that's usually in a car
or something like that you know
it's a very treacherous little community
here isn't it
very much i mean i've lived here for
four years and there's been about a
shooting a week
since i've been here and i hear it too
you know
all right connor well thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you
i wish you the opportunity get back to
see your daughter
thank you man thank you
you